[Music]
welcome
to the corridor cast
you might notice how
if you're viewing this podcast
everyone's wearing robes
well that's because
[Music]
when you're an influencer
and you influence too hard sometimes you
need an influencer robe to chill out
yes and therefore
we have our chill out robes on sent to
us courtesy
of influential
companies right wow what a start what a
start um
this is the chill cast we've never done
a chill cast before but
there's a couple rules to the chill cast
okay
number one your the volume of your voice
cannot get too high
certainly
yeah if if everyone else is like yo
chill out
you have to chill out right sounds great
and then if everyone is like hey
so
you know how do you how do you feel
about this then you have to be like well
you know
you have to start everything with well
you know mm-hmm
or something like that i don't know can
you fire it
yeah i think we need more of this chill
because the world's pretty crazy right
now
and uh yeah man you know
there's a lot of hot takes going around
i mean remember when you first put on
that rope nick and you put it on to
defend to fend off you know creator
burnout yeah dude my depression went
away instantly
you put it on when you were in the wind
the winter of a creator burnout yeah man
so youtube we
we get these boxes from youtube
wasn't this didn't we think it was the
play button oh wait twice
yes yeah you did
let me see let me get i have a box let
me go get it it's got what they sent us
this year okay and i don't think i've
ever shown these on camera live unboxing
yeah let me go get it real quick that's
super cheap so just some backstory
youtube
likes to send its top creators
um
i don't know if we qualify anymore but
apparently we do but they like to send
you gifts every year so
a couple years ago we we had just passed
a million subscribers on the crew
channel and there's a video about this
you can go watch it it's pretty funny
but
we kept expecting to get this play
button and like
these boxes kept arriving and they
contained
robes and other sorts of funny like
little other gifts and it was such like
a buzzkill every time
but it was pretty they gave us creator
burnout cream for like they gave us like
face cream it was the weirdest
all right so
these ones these are the these are the
cool creator burnout pajamas that they
sent us this what they got
they sent us like these fancy
boxes
try it on first jake within these
rooms
should i go off okay do you want me to
go off camera and put these on to turn
into
man you know all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna put these on in the corner and
then i'm gonna come back in these
jammies that i've never worn okay all
right we're gonna be ready yeah we'll be
here man recline 45 degrees here here i
go
okay
there he goes do you think it's a onesie
i hope it's onesie rtp
these are coming back two-piece pajamas
aren't very chill that's like that's
like uppity it's like 50s vibes
yeah with the lapels yeah remember they
used to wear like night caps to sleep
like the 1850s i have never once gone to
sleep and been like man i really wish i
was wearing a hat right now it'd be
perfect
and then in the cartoons they would be
like
the thing like it's flickers apparently
i mean it's because people used to live
in these homes that had no heating so
it'd be cold as
yeah
and like you don't want to keep the fire
going i mean you could but you know it
could get really smoky in there
um
so yeah you'd wear a nice little night
cap
there it is wow all right y'all dude
what a creator
i'm just chilling in my creator burnout
james is there one zero two piece
it's a two piece okay okay but still
check these out yo i'm gonna be honest i
was not expecting that you look super
chill right now dude
join the party man i opened the box and
i said the exact same thing i said i'll
be honest i was not expecting this
not sure what to do with this but these
are way too cool
for me you know
i'll just stick with the cut off jean
shorts and a t-shirt thank you don't
sell yourself short jake come on
speaking of cool
we have a new member of the cast with us
today everybody welcome jordan
everyone welcome griffin
that's right we haven't even talked
about who's here because we've been so
chilling
yeah
we're two children
to bring in someone you know that's
right we we got nick we got jordan
and of course
new member griffin have you ever been on
the cast before i've never been on the
the podcast before
i've been here been here for a little
while but um well welcome this never
happened
welcome welcome welcome it's from making
thumbnails
i mean i have to say like coming in on
the the chill cast is really nice
because i was a little nervous i was
like okay what are we gonna be talking
about is it going to be one of those
crazy big conversations are we going to
be talking about like really in-depth
filmmaking stuff and i'm going to have
to be just on it the whole time no
we're chilling we're listening to thumb
piano we're in robes
you don't have to say anything is that
tear drinking
this is cold brew coffee even better
come on you know griffin
cold brew is the chillest coffee so
chill griffin what's the most red bull
you've ever drank in a day
oh geez dude in 24 hours
probably around there i mean
nine red bulls a couple months ago i was
like coming in and drinking two four
packs a day so that's like dude
that's why we were going through this so
fast
that is not good for you dude i'm coming
in straight up scene griffin in the
morning
and i feel like i'm feeding his
addiction because guess who puts in the
red bull orders right and then we're
like jordan we need more red bull please
yeah and then order
yeah you could see them in cardiac
arrest one day
and there's just griffin just starts
freaking out and throwing chairs you
were drinking so you were drinking two
pints of red bull a day that sounds
about right yeah and i'd usually have a
cup of coffee in the morning before i'd
come to work so
did you notice any uh residual effects
from this sort of habit
um
not this time around i
i go through every once in a while my my
caffeine intake gets really really bad
yeah and then i'll have to kind of you
know chill out on it
what do you consider to be bad well
there was in about like milligrams a day
can you give me an estimate i i can't
give you milligrams a day but i used to
be a two pot of coffee a day drinker
and like it got like my eyes started
twitching and pulling like i gotta do
math on that full pots of coffee yeah
like like uh 10 10 cup pots it has to be
like 600 milligrams of caffeine 10
cup pots yeah so 26 yes yeah i was
wearing 20 cups of coffee
that's 1200 mil how much caffeine can
kill you
really quickly i think about this every
day
i'm just going to google this really
quickly who died of just having heart
attacks from caffeine i'm like
i was worried for you when you're at
your peak man yeah well you get into
these cycles where it's like
you get really tired to drink a bunch of
caffeine because you you need to keep
going and then you wake up the next day
even more tired and like yeah
you're just gonna have to have a day or
two where you're just real tired and you
get out from under it and
you can't keep that up forever like
that's not good i just watched a ted
talk over the weekend about the effects
of alcohol and caffeine on your brain
when you're sleeping and you know you'll
drink a glass of wine before bed
and you think that you're sleeping
enough because you don't wake up or you
don't remember it but what you're not
getting is your it's like the rem sleep
or the oh the rapid eye sleep is what
they call it you're not getting it and
you like you you wake up feeling groggy
and you're like oh but i slept enough
so you don't correlate it to the alcohol
and the caffeine
but then you wake up and you're like
well now i need two cups of coffee now i
need three cups of coffee yeah but
you're not correlating to the fact that
you're just overdoing the caffeine
because it's just right in your brain
that's something that okay
uh here we go guys death by caffeine is
rare
but one study uh identified 51 caffeine
related deaths
um
and 14 of 26 caffeine overdose reports
resulted in death okay so how much
caffeine did they drink
um
many of these caffeine related deaths
were associated with exposure on the
order of
10 grams of caffeine or more not
milligrams 10 grams of caffeine oh man
one person who died ingested 51 grams of
caffeine you see that sounds like one of
those people who like sees that you can
buy powdered caffeine on amazon and
they're like
i wonder if i did a line of this like
nothing bad could happen
it can
that's a thousand one gram is a thousand
milligrams so
if you're drinking 600 if you're
drinking 1200
uh milligrams of caffeine a day that's
still only 1.2 grams
so their heart obviously just stopped
that's still a ton of caffeine but
a very unhealthy amount
do not recommend
it's not chill
so you're
you're doing good griffin
yeah griffin you need the brush man
he's doing better than those people
i mean i drink i drink two to three cups
of coffee a day now that's very healthy
i drink compared but on top of yeah
red bull i'm the same way now man i
drink about two
two to three
that that feels like a good hormone like
five
yeah there's about 60 milligrams of
caffeine and a cup of coffee so you're
talking
180 to
two under under 250 roughly
depending on
how big your cups are
dean cut out caffeine all together
he's like two months in that's crazy
that guy's crazy though you can't get
did he cut out sugar yet
no he didn't but he came to me and he
told me he's like i've noticed no
difference
um i wonder if it's just more like the
lasting long-term effects like
caffeine's super like harsh on like the
heart the bladder
the mind the teeth i mean it's always
good i guess to be
not really the coffee's better thing
yeah
but uh
so griffin
yeah
let's get into this you are a full-time
youtube thumbnail artist
dude it's yeah griffin griffin you've
never been on the thumbnail there you've
never been on the uh the podcast but
you've made all the thumbnails yes yeah
what is this like for you magnificent
it's kind of weird because i'm thinking
about like oh i'm gonna have to cut my
own face out later and put it on the
thumbnail
oh yeah
okay here's the first time why don't you
just give yourself a nice asset to use
right now all right here we go i always
have to like yeah straighten the camera
where's the camera let's make your job
easier on yourself
you're the third yeah oh that's a good
one that's a great one you know i will
say when you do my faces i feel like
you're always adding like five extra
pounds to my face
did i look don't i look like a little
child
yeah it's all in the face jordan yeah
that's what i've noticed i mean i
i'm sorry if you're if you're unhappy
with the faces i'm choosing i always do
go out of my way to try and find what i
consider to be flattering pictures of
everything so i'm just i just look like
that though that's fine that's just
that's what i needed to know
that's real that's real good and you do
like a softening pass on my skin too you
know just yeah moisturizer
toned me up a little bit
but griffin i think the question that
would be would be useful to ask is is
how how do you how did you get to a
point in your life where you make
thumbnails
primarily for a living
you make other stuff too obviously i
don't want to decredit that you make all
kinds of other art but
you know
like half of your workload
is thumbnails did you ever imagine
yourself doing this
yeah and then a follow-up question would
be uh
what do you do
to like perfect this craft
but let's start with the first one how
did you get to this point
um
i got to this point
basically by just continually
taking the next step that seemed fun at
the time
i
absolutely never would have imagined
that this would be my career after
four or five years out of college like i
wanted to design skateboard decks when i
was 21 and like
full size ones yeah full yeah okay or
finger skateboards you know or album art
like
i
wanted to be somewhere totally different
but i just kept getting you know i'd get
i got my first job out of college was a
marketing job a very white collar
very dull but very you know stable
decent job
i got hired somewhere else kept going
down the advertising track ended up
in youtube because i had
some photo composite chops from previous
jobs i had some marketing chops and like
i just kept going for things that seemed
interesting and like sometimes a job i
would get into it and i'd be like oh
this actually is not at all what i want
to do
and sometimes you leave a job and you
know
oh well these are the aspects that i
liked about that and these are the
aspects i didn't
and so i've just kept going after what
seems like it'll be fun like i don't
have like a
an exact plan that you know everything
will work out perfect it's just
what was your degree in
sorry just
i'm curious yeah i got a bfa in
illustration okay
i thought you were going to say like
geology or something
i almost got a minor in geology
it was funny you say that
dude
wow it's random
um yeah another so
imagine
griffin skateboard let's talk about
skateboard decks for a second that's
pretty cool
can you design one for everyone in the
studio
um
[Laughter]
but like we could do that you know and
then we could put them on the wall
mm-hmm and everyone could everyone could
have their own
custom deck design
you already know what's gonna be on mine
that'd be you know what let's um michael
scott
let's have a meeting let's have a
meeting about that after son of a
dungeon wraps how about that that would
let's do that man that'd be fun man
that would be really cool let's let's
make him do this while he's doing this i
like that request
the water job here it's like hey griffin
can you just like uh decide on a
skateboard deck for everyone in the
studio so we can put him on the wall
real quick
and he's like
yeah sure
i'm just oh my god i'm just i'm just
like uh
i'm not gonna do negative self-talk
because we're being chill today but i'm
just i will always say yes and always be
like of course i can do that and then
like as they're walking away i'm like
sorry that's how we're gonna wait till
after
you open your private photoshop file and
like
[Laughter]
oh okay here let me recline for a bit
griffin we just i just did this to you
last last week on instagram on the
instagram story uh
buttons
are those up now yeah those are right
you guys just posted those i threw a
screenshot in the um
let me see
oh it looks so good mm-hmm
don't click
kiss
kiss that looks good so griffin
is it true you worked for the onion
before working here
i did work for the onion and click hole
um
for a brief time in 2017 and 2018. okay
did you just do all those wacky
photoshops in their articles because
there are some great ones that's like my
favorite part about the onion i did a
couple a couple notable ones i
i worked in the editorial side for i
think two or three months and then i got
moved to sponsored content
um but there are a couple
notable ones like um
some of my better ones were for click
hole like um
what was it
inspiring this inner city teacher gained
75 pounds so that his students could
have a big belly to play with
i read that article
i photoshopped a picture of mitch
mcconnell um dragging an office chair
through the the capitol building and
scratching up all the floors
that was a weird weird job man
that was a weird job
i've been a ton of like
i was i was michael flynn i was um a
bunch of like random politicians and
then they would just like cut my my head
off and like
put the politician's head on my body
you're like you do this one i'm too
close to it
they just need to put you in a
cornflower blue shirt
and a tie and that's you're good to go
yeah pretty i mean there
there are a lot of people in politics
with my body i will say that
yeah it's that little did you got that
politician
this slender bod
just without the tattoos
yeah you had to cover those up with a
bunch of politicians who do you think
the first president is gonna be with
tattoos
do you think that's going to happen at
any point president brody hey but what
if like we just haven't seen the attack
trent
oh okay i mean like uh kanye west
like an open uh like a an obvious tattoo
um you know like a neck tattoo six nine
is that is that too much of a stretch
dude kanye
kanye i think kanye's president
he's the most viable prop he's most
viable product for president with tattoo
at the moment
absolutely
he was he definitely got close he got a
couple votes for sure
yeah he got close
he got closer than six nine
he's closer than me
today's episode is brought to you by
manscaped now you've probably tried
other landscaping techniques on your
body but what you probably haven't done
is tried one with a precision engineered
tool like manscape's lawnmower 4.0
that's right they've just introduced the
fourth generation of their premier body
scaping trimmer it's a sleek
well-designed optimized trimmer that
makes shaving time easy and enjoyable
this 4th generation trimmer features a
cutting edge ceramic blade which reduces
accidents while grooming through their
advanced skin safe technology that's
right and the lawnmower 4.0 even has
additional grooming guards sizes one
through four so you can customize the
length and style of your particular cut
oh and did i mention it has wireless
charging pretty great they even added an
led flashlight so that it's a little bit
easier to see down there when you know
you're you're doing your business so if
you're interested in getting a better
groin and body trimmer buy a tool and a
company that's built specifically for
this purpose consider heading over to
manscape.com and using the code cord or
cast 20 to get 20 off your purchase and
free worldwide shipping so thanks to
manscape for sponsoring today's episode
and now back to the podcast
um
so
griffin uh
okay can i really can we realistically
do these skateboard decks though or is
this something that you don't want to do
anymore i'm just trying to play you said
when you're 21 you wanted to design
skateboard decks
well this is a chance to do it we're
going to give you your choice about
living out your dreams griffin
getting like
getting more chances to just make cool
art on the clock like yes i will
definitely go for that or what about an
idea
we do
daily
or every other day or like weekly comic
strips
on the website and it's just like three
panel
dry humor griffin jokes oh you know with
like
it's like dry humor brought to you by
jordan and griffin with stick figure
animation
or stick figure type drawings and then
like little little jokes you know like a
newspaper article maybe we we could we
could talk more about that
maybe not daily though that's a lot
right
yeah a lot yeah i have one on my fridge
that wendy and i laminated
it's a it's a coffee cup
and it's it's an atom it's a anamorphic
coffee cup right it's got eyes and a
nose and hands and stuff
and then there's a traveling mug
and it's also
you know got eyes and nose and stuff and
it's looking there it's a couple
and the coffee bug is looking at the
traveling mug
and it's saying
you're never home
hey
can you do that griffin can you do that
at first at first i thought the punch
line was that they were a cup bowl
and there's layers to this there is
layers that's maybe that's our follow-up
i feel like you could do it if we just
like
put you in an office like a sunny office
with a whole pot of coffee for like the
first half of every day and then
build me a basement here
i'll move my plant next to you
give you all the good vibes like yeah
you need like an eccentric like
plant and stone and book vibe like one
of those airy places airy hipster vibes
i feel like i mean can
can we just take the the back supply
closet that's like
and just like sure put me in there with
like one light bulb i i kind of need to
like cave up okay
you're a cave guy we're definitely a
cave
yeah yeah can we keep the coal back
there in the fake blood yeah okay
absolutely that's even better it's a
good aesthetic only if after every
render you complete back there you come
out like screaming like a monkey like
and you hold up oh i will i will you
have you have a physical
representation of it that you can put in
people's faces
you have yourself a deal there jake
okay all right yeah we can we can clear
out the bat closet for you you mean i
can
i will
be called out
called out
hey the man wants the boneyard what can
we do you know give him the boneyard
give him the bones
oh that back what would you say okay
you're the expert on this and it's
something that i think is very important
to making online content
what is what what are the most important
things about a youtube thumbnail that
yes
i mean
i'm sure you've learned a lot while
being here but i know you also had
experience before coming here across the
board what would you say is like if
you're trying to make a hot clickable
youtube thumbnail what do you do
um
i'd say
honestly the most important aspect
and it's one that we i don't think we
think about a lot because we have it
pretty locked in for our channels is
getting the tone right
because
there have been times when we've
or i should say i because i'm the one
making it so i should own it like there
have been times that i've i've missed
the mark tonally
and
you can see a pretty dramatic drop in
views sometimes and what i mean by the
tone is like
if i'm going on youtube to look at sweet
videos of blue whales
i'm gonna look for just like a nice
still image of a blue whale underwater
the little yellow national geographic
logo
and i'm gonna go you know this looks
like it's gonna be just some sweet
video of blue whales i'm not going to be
looking for like a blue whale
you know with the saturation crunched up
and a white outline and like
what this animal will shock you like if
i see that i'm probably going to go like
well
that doesn't really fit what i'm looking
for so like same with
whatever kind of content you're making
sure if you're making
you know
i would categorize corridor crew as like
um
fun educational
pretty funny a lot of the time
um
and
i don't know youthful maybe i don't know
what other words to to go with but like
we definitely tend to go with like kind
of you know bright colors
yeah
nice clear imagery people having fun
and so when you when you see a chord or
crew thumbnail
you i i at least hope get the sense of
like oh this is going to be like this
group of goofballs who know what they're
doing and they have a blast doing it
yeah
and so if you're trying to make your own
thumbnails for your own channel
just try to pick imagery that reflects
what you make because if
you aren't representing that then the
the people who you're trying to attract
might not find your video yeah yeah
i think that's a valuable lesson for
sure
youtube's hard though man it's hard
because i find
i see a lot of channels like smaller
channels i follow
they do their best to
keep their thumbnails very like you know
like their videos are educational like
history channels or whatever
you know it's like we're talking about
serious stuff i'm a scholar so i'm going
to keep my thumbnails very scholarly and
like
kind of plain but very like educational
and i feel like you always need to add
like 20 percent zaniness
into anything on youtube even if
like because then you see other channels
who are doing the same thing and they
have that zaniness
yeah whether it's like it's that whole
unanswered question element yeah to the
thumbnail you know you pose a question
that maybe necessarily people didn't
know
would be asked is that mystery element
dare i say click bait element well
okay so that's a great segue because
today
derek from veritasium released a video
uh called we need to talk about
clickbait and he uh basically breaks
down
how his realization over time
um was kind of two aspects
one uh
he when he was too
when he was too truthful and with
withheld information
about it's more about withholding
information than it is about being
truthful the truth aspect is about
picking
what thing
you know but i'll talk about the first
one first and that's
uh
you
you you cannot withhold
like the most important aspects
of
the content
in the thumbnail if if the most
important aspect of the content isn't in
the thumbnail
then
you're going to lose viewers
because you're not you haven't you
haven't crossed the threshold into like
in peaking interest but then obviously
you can take that too far say your video
is about
you know
uh
santa claus
and you don't even have an image of him
in the thumbnail well obviously
you know that's going to be that's going
to be a problem but then you take it to
the other side when you get into click
bait which is the word you know that
that everyone hates because click bait
is associated with now you click on
something
but it you but immediately
right it's not there's no follow-through
it's like the image that you saw and the
title the thing that you clicked on that
you wanted to see does not pay off
in the video it's a
lie yeah and so there's a line between
like stretching
how much interest you can peak with
somebody
versus also keeping it
uh
truthful to what your video is actually
about and that's all that's always the
line that
we're we're playing with right because
you want to try to have it be as
attractive to the most amount of viewers
as possible
while at the same time following through
on the promise of the premise that
you're presenting to somebody
to somebody
yeah and that's that's what this video
is about
interesting i gotta watch that man that
sounds like you should how relevant yeah
he does he does i mean it's kind of like
a master class for people who are
looking to start their youtube channel
it's like
it's it's a pretty incredible video yeah
yeah when he was changed his asteroid
thumbnail
i can't remember what the first thumb
was but the second one was like
asteroids you should watch out for he's
just like oh yeah top 10 asteroids you
should watch out well it's funny because
that that uh
thumbnail that he uses for that video
now let me see if i can pull it up
he gained an extra nine million views
he'd change the thing these are the
extras to worry about okay
so
check out that video it's called these
are the asteroids to worry about it's on
derek's veritasium channel and then tell
me how similar that is to ren's
scale of the universe
thumbnail they're very similar
but what each of them do and i'm not
saying you know we have some sort of
right to that type of thumbnail or
anything like this is
you know he made a great video and he
got more people to view it by having a
banging thumbnail so that's good um but
it the thing that that one does is it
immediately poses
the scale of the asteroids to the scale
of earth
in the same image it gives you that
information in the thumbnail
right it doesn't withhold it and it
feels like you're getting attacked by
the asteroid you're like oh i should
probably look on this my life's
endangered by an asteroid that's not
even here
yeah so
yeah
that's but it's an interesting way to
look at it you know with the idea of
like
are you withholding information or are
you adding information that you're not
actually paying off
and where where in those where on each
of those spectrums are you
yeah i think that's where we we do an
okay job of drawing the line is we never
i mean click bait sure like
we're in the business of clicks of
course they're gonna try to bait people
into clicking like i don't think that's
really a negative thing
but
usually we don't i can't think of a time
when we put something in a thumb where
it hasn't actually been in a video yeah
we try to at least like we try to make
it worth your while it's like we want
you to click but because we we think
you're going to really like this video
yeah not because you guys thought about
it with the with the lightsaber video a
little bit yeah yeah we discussed it we
discussed the merits of including uh
old and old and young luke skywalker in
that but ultimately that does like you
were saying in our conversation about
that that thumbnail does
represent what that video ultimately
begins which is the question of the
evolution of the lightsaber over time
best represented by luke skywalker
holding a lightsaber yeah
it's interesting to see like
perspectives though because sam was like
yeah i just watched a video on youtube
that had a visual that i never got to
see in the video and he was like wait
like did i miss that part and he was
like scrubbing back through it because
he thought he missed it it's a stretch
like i guess i could see how people
would be like
that's annoying yeah oh it's very
annoying i mean it i guess it gets you
know
interaction and it gets more watch time
maybe for people i don't know
yeah but um i think a really like a
really helpful way to think about it is
like
something
and i think i've said it in the company
chat
probably a bunch of times but like
a thing that i always try to keep in
mind that i've picked up
like from my my time in advertising is
like
good and bad marketing is like
you don't want to try and
trick people into looking at something
you want to help the people who you're
pretty sure will want this find it
because like people people hate being
sold to like i
i hate when i see a commercial i'm like
oh you're pandering to me so hard right
now but like
you don't need to like trick people into
buying stuff it's like there's people
who
there are some people out there no
matter what you make who are going to be
interested in what you have help them
find what you have yeah
yeah
i think that's really good advice
because
yeah it's it's it always feels cheap
when somebody is
is pandering to you
you know no matter the context
um i'm trying to look up the analytics
for the uh
uh ren competes to win clint's cgi
contest video because we che we recently
changed the thumbnail
in that um
in in that piece
and i think there's too much data now to
see if there was any true bump
in viewership but
um that's another interesting thing that
comes up in that video in the in in
derek's video is he's saying how
often they'll go back
they'll have two to three sometimes four
thumbnails
and they'll just change them out if like
it's underperforming
and
you know see if any of them
do anything yeah
i remember he was talking about that he
was basically saying like people would
think like oh you guys are trying to get
your viewers to re-watch it re-click on
it and he's like no no we're trying to
get
people who haven't seen the video to
come and click on it has nothing to do
with tricking people to re-watch it it's
all about why is this video
showing five million less than usual
let's get those five yeah and that i
think that's a technique that we don't
use maybe nearly enough
honestly is like the idea of hey can we
change out these thumbs if if a video is
not performing
griffin's like no no we do it we don't
we do it
[Laughter]
you have to make what five assets per
video
yeah already here wait yeah so what are
they
um youtube thumbnail website thumbnail
app thumbnail
uh website hero image app hero image
and apparently now youtube thumbnail to
youtube thumbnail three
yeah but no there are definitely times
when it's like
there's a thumbnail like a video that
comes out
and
sometimes you do everything right and
you still
do not quite as well as you'd hoped but
there's definitely times when it's like
oh you know what
i wonder if we just tweaked the text in
this thumbnail if it would if it would
help out and
we could do we could do more of that
yeah i mean that's a very i think
important
aspect i mean you have the image in the
thumbnail but you also have the title
pairing and you have the i mean we often
do in thumbnail captions so there's like
the three that we're always thinking
about like and how do they all pair with
each other like you don't want to pair
a merlot
with you know some cheddar cheez-its or
whatever you know no
wait you don't
that's what i do all the time
come on jake
[ __ ] this gets the slurpee cup of merlot
speaking of cheeses speaking of
cheez-its they're little cheesy snacks
even though they're golden um
yeah
wait a minute
okay so i'll bring this up i'll bring
this up
often i think i think the caption i mean
look at the satisfying render challenges
i feel like the caption this is so
satisfying is like
the most eye-catching thing about those
thumbnails like and the faces of sam and
nico the faces are good but the the
caption contextualizes the faces yes
because that face could be anything that
could be sam you know
scared pooping or anything yeah
right but uh so i don't know it's always
a balance we're always trying to
and if one of those aspects is off then
like there's this
this balance imbalance exactly and also
it also comes down to like finding what
works for you you know and and this this
applies to a lot of different aspects in
the artistic process and in other
processes as well but you know
like don't just
i mean we've seen
the other day i was throwing up uh one
of the thumbnails that i found
um onto the discord
and it was people who had taken
the world's longest lightsaber video and
then like reef re basically re-shot it
but did the exact same framing
and use the same vfx element that we
have in ours and then re-named it
something like super similar or even the
exact same video title and then did that
pay off at all
i think it does
in the video
that video i believe
has nothing to do let me just type it in
world's
longest lightsaber
yeah that's like a compliment okay yes
here it is here it is okay
i found it
uh
okay
this video
is about him
playing some star wars game
uh but the thumbnail
is
literally
him going oh in the corner and then he
retook a picture of himself
doing the exact same pose that nico's
doing photoshopped him over nico and
then added extra flames to the
to the jet
and and
it's called the world's longest
lightsaber i assume at some point in
this
17-minute video he attempts to create a
world's longest lightsaber in game but i
you know could just be total click bait
um insane and then there's another one
gta 5 the longest lightsaber ever guys
doing the exact same thing
uh
and then there's another one that i
found where literally it's this it's
just these it's like these indian bros
and they're just they just recreate
the entire video
but
like they shoot their own version of it
and they call it the exact same thing
well you know what's crazy is i get a
lot of emails that i have to look
through that are about people
wanting us to pay them to make our
thumbnails and i'm like have you looked
at our youtube channel i was like
well they're just spamming they're just
trying to get but they like really think
they're like we can help your workload
and i'm like well griffin would probably
love that i'm like griffin's doing the
best and people are copying our
thumbnails it's like i don't think just
send that email right back yeah
and this would be like no we can help
you
you just start freaking outsourcing
we've got a guy
we got a guy named griffin
he's making way too much coffee but my
point with that whole spiel about the
world's longest lightsaber is
if you look at
like
you know each channel who i guess is
respected by the rest of the community
you can see that they each have their
own style
like they all yeah they all utilize
similar techniques you know isolation
don't withhold information try to make
it the most intriguing you can you know
pique the interest of the viewer all
that stuff
and don't lie but at the same time
they all have
their sort of individual
elements that no other channel is doing
and that's a like an interesting thing
to note too is like much in the same way
as like you know you have two guitarists
or or whatever what have you
um two filmmakers
in the same way you you can have two
different
artists you know graphic artists who are
going to give you
this the product isn't going to
accomplish the exact same thing but
in terms of like
look at it over time and extrapolated
over time
you're gonna see very consistently like
this is this style
um
and uh i i don't think people consider
that at first they just go oh well this
this worked so i'll just copy this but
there's a difference between
taking cues
and taking information that people give
you what for what you know works for
them
and taking that into your like tool box
and just aping somebody's style yeah
they think it might like say it does
good one time they copy someone's swag
but you don't really get retention
with that yeah like you know
yeah
so don't be derivative there's another
lesson for thumbnails
create your own pattern you know and
stand out or be 80 derivative but 20
original
[Laughter]
as long as it's yeah well if you're
making lightsaber related videos that
have to do with cutting planes in half
though
you know what's you know something
really funny that i noticed um
we were having a conversation at one
point a couple of weeks ago about
the similar similarities and differences
between
film posters and thumbnails
and how
in a lot of ways there's a lot of
similarities like you know readable from
a distance gives you an idea of what
you're in for if you watch this wants to
get you excited
and after that conversation
i started to notice in a lot of like
film posters and like billboards for
films and tv around town
them literally using like thumbnail
making techniques like i can't remember
the name of the show but i was um
driving down olympic and there was this
like billboard for a show
and i noticed the person in the
billboard had the whites of their eyes
like fully blown out like painted white
like you would for a thumbnail yeah i
mean like almost any poster you see
these days and i mean even back in the
day
has some sort of massive face in it or
that's the main compositional element
but for sure that those like
quote more janky aspects that we yet you
get away with on the tiny thumbnail size
are now becoming
like more relevant to
all imagery
because of just the
i think it depends on what the utility
is for the image i mean usually we're
actually working with a post artist who
does a lot of like
like he does a lot of stuff that you'll
see on like streaming services and he
was explaining how
you know he has to make like three
versions he has to make one mobile for
the streaming mobile
just like you're saying he has to do one
for like you know when you're just
scrolling through on amazon prime and
your tv's on the other wall and it's
like
you know effectively this big
and then he has to make one that's meant
to be on a wall where people are staring
at it
like you know huge yeah like because
it's right in the movie theater exactly
yeah
so
there's different
compositional elements that they
deliberately or they deliberately add
into each one of those you know
as you would i think the janky stuff
starts coming in when it's small like a
thumbnail because people don't notice it
and it's all about what pops
billboards and thumbnails are definitely
like even when you think of how many
words are supposed to go on there i
think it was like no more than like
seven or
something i took an advertising class we
had to make billboards yeah if your
sentence was too long she would like
that's all an automatic like
let her down she's like no she's like
who is going down the street and can
read two sentences worth of stuff
you're right
and no one wants to sit there and read
that for a thumbnail either pull your
car over
yeah because you have to finish reading
wait hold on mom hey kids are you
interested in that one
okay okay all right let's keep going
okay
by sentence three you're like oh that's
not for me
[Laughter]
god i got to make one billboard in my
life so far and it was
it was super simple it was really boring
but
sometimes it's more about like
getting like especially in advertising
like getting the objective across yeah
and it's like
in this case it was like
tagline logo phone number
that's it i you know what's crazy i made
a billboard and it went up no really
yeah
now knowing now knowing this i was so
underpaid
but it was the billboard back in
pensacola pensacola's sheriff uh yeah it
was his first sheriff and it was uh two
sheriffs on the
billboard and he was talking about how
god was so long ago and i want to say it
was about locking your doors
hey lock your door
maybe the okaloosa county sheriff's
department where i'm from
man i have to go back because i can go
find them like they're like my indesign
files and like all of that
yeah because i was starting to try to do
um
like contracted out work with like
graphics and stuff like that it was just
it was like super tedious and i didn't
like take it serious enough then i just
stopped doing it but i feel like is it
sheriff morgan says lock your doors keep
it yours
wait i don't know i want to see what it
looks like
is it green is the thumbnail green uh no
thumbnail it's yellow and black yellow
and black they ripped you off jordan
yeah i'll find it i'm gonna find it and
show you guys you should get royalties
every time someone doesn't lock their
doors
and then you get the stuff that they
lost yeah and they don't lock their
doors my p.o box is overflowing yeah
it's a perfect scheme it's a perfect
racket
all right um
jordan there's another thing we need to
discuss here today what could we
possibly have to talk about jake
i
see i haven't seen this yet but i'm on
the youtube studio side of the corridor
crew channel right now
and what i see is an expressvpn
integration
for this weekend
and
you know
i don't know what i see here jake you
did that integration didn't you yeah i
thought i did i thought i did this
integration let me just hashtag battle
of the brands
so listen
oh man what did you guys do
don't watch it jake that's fine it done
me dirty you did a good job jake if you
want your night ruined watching okay
here here's the deal croutons okay you
know how we had wesley and wesley
incorporated okay and and and
you know it was about
wesley and wesley was about you know
looking out for each other
but then this whole thing came along so
quick and now this this j and j's
it's completely integration
it's crumbling
and
look i'm just gonna say this weekend i
don't know what's gonna happen on the
integrations on the videos i just know
something's brewing
and
you guys gotta go watch the video and
find out yeah
i mean saying jay that implies you guys
are working together i thought we were
that's the thing i thought i think i
think we are i think we're just we
we rushed into this and we need to just
slow it down and really understand you
know where we're coming from
it's it's like any relationship you
gotta take it slow understand
don't worry absolutely jake
you've uh you've been with us for a
while and you know you've done a great
job but
it's not personal we're just we're just
thinking of going in a different
direction i know it's like i'm the old
quarterback
i'm the old quarterback i get it it's
like
look
you know on the office when creed dyes
his hair we've been you've been with us
for 10 years and we've won two super
bowls um but you know maybe it's time to
start thinking about
you know how to keep those as memories
listen buddy you've sold a lot of recons
all right and we really appreciate that
i think it's time here's a pair of
raycons put it in your box
put it in your box
um yeah yeah for anyone who hasn't been
uh you know watching the sponsored ads
in our videos jordan has been uh
moving in on jake's jake's job here
and takes a sip of beer yeah yeah
getting a bit spicy so
let's get it so look out stay tuned
we'll see how it develops here yeah
that's um
it's been a run i don't know what's
gonna happen from here yeah
i think it's gonna be a blast
i think i think in the next one i'm
gonna have to bust out my influencer
pajamas i think that's what's gonna have
to happen uh-oh
all right man just don't careful not to
burn out jake all right on influence
don't over infuse we'll send you a robe
though
if you burn out we'll send you a rope
you better it is possible
to over influence griffin had to take
off his robe he got over influenced dude
it was
it was so warm
do you have any goodies in the pockets
of your robe i'm curious because i have
super i have some real fun surprises
maybe i have a magic card
it's a it's a basic land card it's a
mountain oh because i'll say i'm over in
the code before i don't know this is
just what's in them i did not play why
the hell is there a magic card nerf nerf
darts of course oh you know what jan
wore this
for sure
how many nerf darts do you have in there
no it's like a whole pack i have seven
snaps
nerf darts sorry that wasn't i'm just
gonna put those back in for the next guy
who needs to use that would cost you
like six bucks at target true man
i'm rich
you're dart rich dude
so so we talked about the battle of the
brands what else is going around the
studio here
what's what's new guys well okay so next
week
i'm excited about this um and we can
talk more about this uh you know as we
get into things maybe even on the
podcast next week but
nick and i for months has been eagerly
developing research and development you
know we've had we've had money out to
third-party firms you know we've had
we've we've done test groups okay you
know how they like rate movies we've
brought in sections of the public
we've been testing this idea we're
finally gonna do
an avatar
for me in the studio
we're bringing jake back guys he's gonna
be a regular cast member on the crew
channel because you know living in texas
it's hard for him to participate so it's
yeah like people are thinking about jobs
people are taking my job i can't even
you know i can't even get in on a
meeting anymore yep uh and so we just
figured that it would be best if like we
just made an avatar of me and it's
constantly on
and then i can just access it anytime
precisely it'll have audio visual
technology
it'll have a physical uh let's just say
stature that you know commands respect
and it also
if if we need
you know we can always bring in
a
a thespian to
to really thespian
take on the jake persona chef's kiss you
know really convince people that it's me
yeah because what i don't want you know
we talk about the uncanny valley and
visual effects right and it's this it's
this valley where you know it's not fake
enough to disregard it and it's not real
enough to be believed well you know the
same thing can happen with an avatar and
we want this avatar to look real we want
it to feel real you know we want to
forget the people to forget that they're
not actually talking to me physically
present there and just be talking to me
you know
i you know what i think it's going to be
a great time
i'm interested to see like how the hair
goes like are you painting it is it
going to be a wig just
we have a whole plan okay there's i'm
saying i had to go pick chemists
that's just the the bones that's that's
just that's just that that's just the
foundation yeah just raw experience i
don't know how this bread is gonna be
this flower it looks very like it
doesn't look white enough like i don't
know this flower but you haven't even
baked it you haven't even baked it it's
just the flour
all right i'm just i'm very ready for
this give us a try and turn it into a
donut it's going to be delicious
can we have any any like
any hints any bread crumbs like
when you say an avatar are we talking
like uh
are you talking like
more like uh inanimate like an ipad on a
roomba or more like it's always sunny
like a like a
living being somewhere right in between
great questions
yeah it is
we've discussed that quite a bit and um
we're going to try a few a few ideas and
do some a b testing in the studio yeah
and we'll see what works best you know
maybe we'll do another test group we'll
see who's like most comfortable with
which design
and then uh
you know we'll kind of settle on it if
people just get free uh yeah i mean one
thing that i'm excited for is bringing
in uh the sun brett driver yeah he he's
gonna be you know i think
taking on the role of jake in in the
physical sense
uh for this project so anyway stay tuned
that'll be a fun video
um you know
i think we can find a way to
you know have jake living in texas yet
still keep his presence here in the
studio more than it has been because
who knows he might not be doing brand
deals very much anymore
and
you know we want to prepare for that he
said i wasn't prepared for it but you
know you got to adapt life is about
adaptation you know survival is about
adaptation
um and just like i adapted in you know i
don't think it's gonna happen but if i
need to adapt out listen if somebody can
do it better than me
then i i'm happy to say
you know
that's the way it is
for sure
you know jordan might be coming for your
your brand job jake but
there's someone coming for jordan's name
next week too
yeah
that's also happening next week yeah
that's a lot
yeah
so this is another another inside
another trouton info um jordan allen who
was with us in a few videos ago what
what video was it
yeah yeah the the clint houdini render
challenge
um so he's coming in he's coming in to
work with us
i'm super excited about it but it also
pretends presents an interesting
predicament what do we do
with jordan here there's two jordans in
the studio
yeah
what was that griffin griffin
yeah griffin does have a really you know
what and i don't hate the idea at all
so griffin wants to have one of them be
called beans
it sounds nothing like jordan
one of them yeah i think you should do a
rock paper scissors for it oh snap i i
mean i share your your
fantasy of having just someone in the
studio called beans
you know i mean how cool it sounds like
he has street cred already yeah i kind
of like it i'm gonna be knife
knife i'm gonna be nice okay maybe when
we hire another griffin
good luck honestly if you find another
griffin to hire him on here
we did bring in another map that was
crazy that was crazy jordan is not
jordan is not nearly as common as matt
and we founded jordan
we've had some really cool guests like
hanging around here the last month yeah
man
really cool people kind of cool
new energy
all of our dead souls here
i mean all these are chill souls chill
so chill that they think we're dead
punching in the tub
it's really cheap a couple other things
that's happening ren has a solar panels
video that's coming out oh yeah the
scale of solar panels to power the
universe
or to power earth or
maybe just the us i don't know
yeah it's all of earth
but i'm very excited for it him and matt
already shot a lot of it and it's in
edit right now and then uh ren's getting
more photography for it this week
um just some b-roll and stuff and uh
then we have a very special
react guest whose name will not be named
at this time
very much looking forward to that and
then um in september
mr luc lafontaine is coming back and we
are doing a sword fight style this is
what real sword fights would look like
style fight yeah um with him so i'm very
excited for that
and finally it's finally time to let him
coordinate his perfect sword fight just
reacting to so many
and after talking about it with him okay
so seriously though when luke the first
time we worked with luke was in
2016
and he was talking about doing a video
like this then so this has kind of been
brewing
for some years for the opportunity to do
something like this so uh wow this is
our chance
and yeah yeah and part of that video i'm
not gonna i'm not sure how much
if i'm like overstepping here but
all i'm gonna say is that
we have the coolest new camera
yes that's literally all say that's all
you can say right now no no no no i'm
not gonna say more
but i will also say that this camera's
gonna change everything and like for
real we we've made like a couple perfect
camera videos and i look forward to
geeking out about this more this is the
2021 update it's it's the 2021 update
without all the separate components it's
just
all in one
and the thing is like think about what a
camera is in your mind
it's the opposite of that
so just going to leave it there but be
excited because this thing's cool it's a
package deal
it's an audio only device
it
yeah
sorry i need to take a chill pill here
and then uh after that
since mid-september
we are i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give
a firm date on this yet but we are
currently on pace
to release son of a dungeon
mid-september and as if we stay on that
pace until mid-september we will be
releasing son of a dungeon mid-september
um so my bone friend's like holy crap
guys one year in development
that's crazy a new look into d and d
so
yeah for all those out there who are
saying we didn't we're not doing
anything narrative anymore i got eight
hours of narrative content coming your
way on corridor digital.com so thank you
very much eight hours that's why i'm
taking over the brand deal so you have
time for this that's right yeah so i
have time to prep season two yeah
son of a dungeon is like high key i
think like
it's like one of the coolest things i've
ever worked on dude i can't wait to
watch it i've seen nothing
i've seen nothing oh yeah you really
haven't and i don't even watch d stuff
but like now i want to no exactly like
i'm looking well you know it is it's d
and it's d and d's narrative so even
though we cut out all the fat you know
it is there is a little bit of a slow
burn but it it means that as it
progresses you get more and more hooked
on what's going to happen
um and i think that's that's kind of
like
that's what makes it good because when
you're looking to watch that type of
content you're not looking for like oh
give me 15 minutes of like you jumping
out of an airplane you know it's it's
like this is this is a story and you
want to get into it you want to sink
your teeth into it and spend time with
the characters
and that's exactly uh what this does
can't wait
definitely gonna start playing
oh we should we should just start doing
like casual we were doing that on
thursdays
we had an office d thing and then covet
happened
yeah um that was when griffin first
started here i think a lot of people who
because like well maybe i won't speak
for other people i'll speak for myself
when before i started playing d d i was
really intimidated by it cause i was
like oh there's all these stats there's
all these things you gotta learn
once you actually sit down and play your
first round of dnd you realize it's just
wizard-themed gambling
and you just sit around with your
friends
you play craps with your friends and you
talk mad [ __ ] and you're like my wizard
blew up your goblin and they're like
cool here eat some pizza like it's so
casual dude it's so much fun
pizza is a must wizard's themed gambling
i've never heard it put like that but it
is hilarious it is not an inept
description by any stretch that's going
to be our dnd t-shirt wizard themed
gambling
wizard crap to need some pizza
[Laughter]
wow man well this was super chill i
think nick's about to fall asleep
i know i mean nick this has been real
nice
how's that is that too loud
yeah okay can you please take a penal
reclamation
that you went over the decibel count i
want to see you recline right now
okay
if you go over the decimal account again
i'm taking squarespace
[Music]
keep it chill guys hey hey that's not
okay
how dare you jordan
jordan how dare you squarespace how dare
you even hint at that
jake has a squarespace shirt that he
made that's like taking my child okay
you can come after vessy's okay you
could come after raycon
but don't you dare
don't you dare take my beautiful
award-winning templates with 24 7
customer service i see a lot of squares
around here
just want to throw out that we we value
all of our brand partners
especially manscaped thanks to them for
sponsoring this episode and uh
you know
and if i could i would take this
and i would take manscape from you too
oh yeah griffin was like should we just
have a video of my back getting shaved
it would have been funny and i would
have gotten a free back shaving so
it's you know people don't realize for
those who have hairy backs it's not very
convenient to shave them yourself so no
do you need like a
oh an extended
an
razor
an extended razor maybe manscaped hasn't
has a solution to that yeah click the
link in the bio to find out more yeah
yeah
find out how you can get
how much 20 off your first purchase
jordan 20 off your first purchase don't
tell me all the details because i have
my problem
cast
dude i hike he need a new beard trimmer
so i might uh
yeah i might
check out that promo code
no this isn't sponsored it's legit oh it
is it's legit
precision precision blades premium
engineering
it's even got a 4 000 kelvin led light
on it
are you gonna put this as part of the
integration ah no i already did the
integration i'm just reciting the
talking points at this point
you can see whether this is on or not
from
space
[Laughter]
that that is not
part of the product description but
it should be disclaimer
all right i think we're done here that
was a chill cast
you guys have anything any other last
words
before we chill out
should we chill out out of
i just hope everyone has a really chill
tuesday evening
nick get the thumb the thumb guitar
play us out
[Music]
all right thanks everybody for watching
and listening
catch us next week here on the chill
cast or maybe another game of spy fall
or
maybe
you know deep insights into the future
of ai
[Music]
next time
on corridor cast
[Music]